[Musique]
le soleil brille la sève coule la saison
du sirop d'érable commence
bientôt en produira du sirop d'érable
classés par sa couleur mais aussi par la
certification biologique
sur un peu plus de 7000 entreprises
acéricoles qui au québec 1100 ont une
certification biologique site à peu près
de 17% des entreprises acéricoles sont
certifiés biologiques par contre au
niveau de la production en volume c'est
environ 40% de la production annuelle
qui est certifiée biologique
depuis 2015 cette production a augmenté
de 250%
c'est un produit que de plus en plus en
demande sur les marchés le sirop
d'érable biologique et surtout et sur
les marchés internationaux on l'achète
en bouteille en conserve dans des
contenants au marketing qui peut parfois
donner l'impression d'un produit encore
plus fins et de meilleure qualité la
certification biologique ne s'attarde
pas à la qualité du produit c'est
vraiment un système certifie les
procédés de production quand une
certification biologique le logo sur une
canne de sirop d'érable on eu
l'assurance qu'elle s'est fait selon des
normes d'environnement
l'utilisation des équipements de lavage
d'assainissement des équipements qui
respectent les normes biologiques par
exemple la tubulure vous savez
maintenant que les érables seront
connectés cet audit urbain dans la non
billon doit utiliser de la coletilla de
l'éthanol quand même étonnant qu'on va
retrouver dans le vin ou dans les
spiritueux on doit utiliser cet étonnant
l'eau pour nettoyer
donc voici le laboratoire analytique
c'est au laboratoire de la chaire de
recherche sur les technologies acéricole
que nous rencontrons le chercheur jean
michel lavoie ici des projets de
recherche seront étudiées comme la
chimie du sirop d'érable on achète
jusqu'à un certain point une certaine
garantie au niveau de la chine s'est pas
exactement exactement la même chose que
pour les fruits et légumes mais ya quand
même un certain parallèle à faire au
niveau de d'avoir la certitude que le
sirop d'érable qu'on va avoir acheté ou
qu'on veut consommer va avoir des
chances très minime d'avoir des certains
éléments chimiques qui devrait
[Musique]
il y à l'équipement le nettoyage et des
normes pour la forêt comme le nombre
d'entaillés sur un arbre là non
biologique quand même certains aspects
qui concernent l'environnement notamment
pour l'aménagement du territoire et le
respect par rapport à l'arbre lui même
donc il pas possible de faire par
exemple du double en taille âge et une
certain nombre d'entaillés maximum qu'on
peut mettre par rapport à un diamant et
d'arbres et on s'assure aussi que la
forêt soit pas un peuplement apur
d'érable il faut que la forêt est une
certaine portion d'autres espèces
en puisant le sirop mousse et déborde
c'est le lot des producteurs de sirop
d'érable
pour casser cette mousse on ajoute de
l'huile végétale on va injecter ce qu'on
appelle des surfactants mais plus
spécifiquement dans le monde biologique
on va utiliser des huiles végétales qui
sont elles-mêmes biologique qu'on voit
injecter sur la mousse c'est quelque
chose qu'on peut agir quand même assez
facilement à la maison au prince si on
veut faire de la tire d'érable ou faire
du beurre d'érable dès qu'on va chauffer
on va voir que ça va commencer à monter
juste envoyer un petit peu de
vaporisateur d'huile végétale voeu de
voir ça va commencer là moi ça va tomber
le même concept utilisé en érablière
lui-même acériculteurs et se souvient
d'anciennes techniques utilisées
historiquement quand j'étais jeune on
utilise un morceau de leur compte 31
qu'avec un espèce de cana page fête
artisanale écuries fils de métal pour
faire descendre la mouche où on
utilisait ce qu'on appelle du bo bo je
vois dans ma famille on disait vous
recherchez montceau bois bois rue on me
suit à travers de la peine qu'on utilise
le sirop d'érable puis j'avais certaines
effet la cuisson nécessite naturellement
un combustible
la certification biologique ne considère
pas l'utilisation du mazout par exemple
dans la certification biologique il ya
des normes environnementales
par contre la norme en pot 1 pour acquis
toutes les missions djs depuis tout
récemment une nouvelle certification que
la certification carbon ult non
classement baroin ce sirop biologique
carbonate ici c'est notre laboratoire
un laboratoire où pourraient émerger des
idées pour améliorer l'empreinte carbone
une scène qui va peut-être 1 2% truc
vers un produit final qu'est le seroquel
66% ce que ça veut dire qu'on enlève de
l'eau puis enlevée de l'eau sa demande
de l'énergie nécessairement c'est sûr
que l'empreinte de carbone et pas
nécessairement aussi grande qu'on va
utiliser du bois quand qu'on va utiliser
un combustible fossile mais si on est
capable de récupérer une partie de cette
énergie locks et plus économique pour le
producteur puis à moins de carbone qui
voit dans la victime lors du brouillage
on revoit des comptes à quand des métaux
et le lait sirop d'érable donc pas voir
certaines transmissions de plomb de ce
côté là mais la plupart des évaporateurs
qui sont produits sont exempts de plomb
tout les sirops d'érable qui passe dans
le processus de contrôle la qualité mais
et la teneur en plomb et les mesures et
les contrôles et donc l'association
biologique ne pas de normes plus se
faire par rapport à ça la production
biologique n'est pas garante de meilleur
goût du sirop d'érable plusieurs
facteurs peuvent influencer le goût ça
devient dur c'est de vraiment des
documents sirop d'érable biologique est
vraiment meilleur ça dépend d'où on va
prendre le sirop d'érable de comment qui
a été fait donc plusieurs points à
prendre en considération
on peut pas juste je crois doivent se
dire il est meilleur au goût ça va être
difficile à déterminer
on choisit donc selon nos goûts nos
convictions et le prix car le sirop
d'érable biologique est plus cher la
plupart des érablières respecte beaucoup
des normes biologiques il ya des choses
qui doivent être faites supplémentaires
mais c'est vrai que au départ on un
produit qui déjà peur qui sort de
l'érable pour monsieur lavoie tout
dépend de notre proximité avec une série
culte heures aller chercher vers un
producteur local empêche que le sirop
d'érable avaient fait une ronde de
promenade autour du québec pour des
entrepôts être embouteillé revenir donc
et certains avantages au niveau des gaz
à effet serre mais aussi juste le bon
voisinage avec les producteurs je trouve
ça intéressant et important d'encourager
cette production acéricole mais ça c'est
bien sûr très personnel c'est mon avis
on ne peut pas accès ce sont qu'on peut
aller vers la biologie pour
éventuellement la carboneutralité
pourquoi
[Musique]